Okay, hello, everybody my name is Markiplier and Don't worry that scared me too! (wuss markiplier)
I just loaded up the game and this is waviolence or wave violence. Type your name and then hit enter
(HOLY MOTHER OF JESUS THAT SCARED ME)Oookay?
Cool! Your name: Mark
Tahahank Cooohohol Ahahahass
My name is barely Mark. Tank. Coolass and
Your Profession: Master Wavethief
Okay
Your mission pretty damn important (Wow that sounds important)
Infiltrate the Mansion construction site(BANG) Steal the McGuffin and get out alive(BANGx2)You are very fragile(BANGx3)
But you are handed the ultimate weapon...... hand waves
(Damn We Got Some Jokes Up In Here)
Pull out your hahahaaand by holding the right mouse button(BANG) Then wave with the left mouse button
Your sheer politeness will litera-(Laughing Mark)lly blow up the guards
(MARK IS LAUGHING WAY TOO MUCH)
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS GAME(You And Me Both)
The Weapon Has A Very Short Range However (I just realised it sounds like mark says driver)
So Use It Wisely Etcetera
Etcetera
Right Thats All Bye
(BIG DADDY SMOKES DOES A ROAR)
What!
OH MY GOD THAT TOP DOWN MAP
Uh.
:locate and steal the McGuffin
Hi. uh... Uhh
(MARKIMOO Laughing Like A Lunatic)
(RANDOM NOISES PLAYED AT EAR BLASTING CAPACITY)
I've Been Cauuuught?!(Yes it seems you have)
That didn't do it?!(You do see the game over screen don't you mark?)
Whoops.
Okay, so apparently I'm supposed to be stealthy about it.
I dunno......
I dunno, man
Hello
oh(MORE EAR BLASTING NOISES)
Okay, that didn't work my wa-
(Mark Laughs Once Again)
didn't work
MY EEEEAAARASSS
(Marks noises confuse me so much)
Wow, okay, all right.
Whatever this game remind me of Burrito Galaxy in a way.
Oh instead of slappin' burritos
You're blowing up guards with a wave of your hand
oh
Hidy Hidy, Hi
Hidy Hidy HOO
(MY EARS BLEED FOR YOU DEAR READER)
The top down is important. I should look at that.
Hey, you shouldn't stand there, ha
(confusing amount of habooskys i prefer not to sub)
(Mark In Shame)
You ready for the waaaaaavee
BOINK
(Mark the witch cackles at the fact his spells worked)
(Hey maybe he should do a subscriber spell)
Okay, right he ho den so that's how-
(I don't even understand what is happening anymore)
(MARKSTIPACION)
WOOOOOOOOOOAAAAH
I can
I can indeed
Okay, all right, then well you guys our days are numbered then
Oh you think you can stop me from stealing your mcGUFFIN. Well? I don't think (I dont even know anymore) BOINK
Fuck I should not risk that
All right, I ge
Gegegege
BAM
Fuck where are you taking me SIR!
excuse you?!
Oh?!
Oh fuck
you.
oops
It don't think that was supposed to be possible
(someone gif that laugh please)
My bad
OOHH
My name is Mark number one(INSERT LAZY TOWN JOKE HERE)
cool
ass
all right now. I got this enough goofing around(WAIT YOU WERE ONLY DUN GOOFIN.)
I'll take this a little more seriously
WHAT DA FUCK
what da fuuuuuuuuck!
Okay, well toast me to victory apparently apparently. I'm just gonna ride this one out. Hey. How's it going guys?
Hey, remember, how I said, I was going to stop dickin around well alas it is not that way
I've got a mobile platform here BAAAM
Okay, who's Gonna died means that the macguffin?
This is the macguffin hello
(Mark has gone insane)(With laughter)
All right, okay now. I'll do it properly
There we go. Yeah, you got to be like on them okay, so there's another patrol coming around that corner
So I need to stay
nice
And stealthy.
So I can either do this one of two ways I could avoid them or I could just blast them all into oblivion
Oh, no
You thought you were gonna. Go home to your family. Where are you going? All so where? Why?
MARK CHOOSING SIDES
Okay
That wasn't supposed to go that way man
It didn't have to go down like that. You made me do that that was not my fault
I'm gonna steal that Mcguffin would you think you can keep the MccGUHffin away from MEEEEEE
OOOH I- (Mark Gets completely caught off guard)
I don't know. How you did that, or why?
The AI is very sensitive here I lucked out on those macguffin blasts
But I can't get so lucky all the time
I gotta actually take this seriously which I have been
Believe it or not. This is me taking it seriously. Oh, God someone's coming, ooh
Doodly-Doo, Doodly-doo
Doodly-Doo
Doodly-Doo, I don't know how far
He's gonna come this way, but if he comes this way enough to get a blast fulla hand
I'm gonna hand them right in the act
I'm just gonna smack that ass and hope for the best.
Oh who knew that markiplier ass
pat's™
we're going to be so
Devastating. ohh I'm ready for you
oh you better turn around
Your mistake you did what I told you to do that was your first mistake. This is your second
MARK SCREAMING LIKE AN ABSOLUTE IDIOT
That got him
They're pretty blind okay
Pretty blind so long as you're (inaudiable)
OOOOOOOOOO
That had more range dude. Why did that have Pep In Itz Step
MARKS PLEASURE MOANS™
their GOOD BYE BEHBEH , okay, so being (inaudiable once again) does help. man it does such a... such a...
Such a shookin thing. Oh
You coming out to inspect the- Ahh Hey Hey
Okay, alright, then okay. Oh, I don't know how you did that
Maybe methinks this game wasn't perfected
We got incoming oh
Right this mcguffin in is mine(Finally.) You come over here your deeeaaheed
OOH YOU DONT WANT NONE O DIS
*Que singing* YOU DON WAN NUNADIS YOU DUN WANT NUNA DIUUUUUSS
Yeah, okay. I got it. I'm on the run. Oh
I got it. I think I got it. Don't come after me. Don't come after me. Don't come after me
OEHOEHOEHOEHOEHOEH
Yeah
WEEEHIIIL
I acquired the macguffin you can now continue on unspecified plans
Look, I'm really drunk. We just have a game here
Thank you. I'm going to bed. Oh
Hope this was good enough (Mark Laughing)
oh game by Alon
"DANCINGGENGIE" Karmz with music by Nathanel Gordon
oh
Well, that's waviolence well the concept is cool like it's obviously rudimentary
But the style that you put into it like my God that was really
Legitimately cool. I enjoyed that a lot
Probably more than I should have but I did
Man either way that is waviolence
Thank you everybody so much for watching you can check out this game through going to the description below let me know what you thought
let me know what you thought of it down in the comments and as always I will see you in the next video.
BuBye!
You still here?
wow
Ya like jazz?
k now leave it's creepy